Elon Musk isn’t known to
keep his opinions to himself.
If you take Warren Buffett, for example. And to
be totally frank I'm not his biggest fan.
That was on Joe Rogan’s podcast last year.
And later, he cast doubt on Buffett’s public image
when asked by the New York Times
whether Buffett was overrated,
saying  that the grandfatherly
figure is “...maybe overstating the case.”
For Buffett’s part, he’s been a
bit tamer when speaking about Musk.
What do you think of Elon Musk, though? Have you
met him and would you invest in Tesla?
(Laughter)
Well, I think you’re trying to bait me a little bit.
Oh no no, I’m not. I’m just asking it. You can
say ‘no, no, and no’ or ‘yes, yes, and yes’.
Listen, he’s done some remarkable things.
The two men are similar in the
sense that they’re filthy rich.
Musk’s net worth is $190 billion dollars.
Buffett’s is over $100 billion.
But dig a little deeper and you’ll see they’re
two very different kinds of billionaires.
(Applause)
Warren Buffett is widely considered
the greatest investor of all time.
He’s the Chairman and CEO of Berkshire
Hathaway - a holding company that has
consistently given its shareholders
returns of around 20% every year.
That’s without heavily
investing in tech companies.
And would you invest in Tesla?
No.
Okay.
He’s largely avoided tech
companies because he famously said he
doesn’t understand them well enough so
it’s hard to estimate their future value.
He admitted he messed up by not buying
shares in Google and Amazon years ago.
And instead of picking individual stocks
to buy, Buffett favors index funds like the
S & P 500 - a pre-set basket of stocks
that offers more safety and diversity.
Buffett prefers playing it safe
by choosing low-risk investments.
His strategy is to buy and hold for decades.
And that’s the fundamental
difference between him and Musk.
Musk is high-risk, high reward with the
potential for very high losses, too.
After making $180 million when the online bank he
ran became PayPal which was then bought by eBay,
he sunk all of the profits into three companies.
If things had gone south, Musk
would have been left with nothing,
but it was a risk he was willing to take.
Buffett tries to protect his shareholders
from as much risk as possible.
He prefers investing in companies that
have large “moats”, not unlike olden day
castles that had a ditch filled with
water encircling them for protection.
In the economic world, a moat protects a company
from the competition by having some sort of
advantage, such as being able to produce at a
lower cost due to cheaper access to raw materials.
Musk doesn’t think this is
the best strategy. He’s said:
“If your only defense against invading
armies is a moat, you will not last long.”
Instead, “What matters is the pace of innovation…”
In his case, that means rapidly building
Starships and scaling up the production of Teslas.
In response, Buffett defended the idea of
moats, saying “Elon may turn things upside
down in some areas. I don’t think
he’d want to take us on in candy.”
Referring to Berkshire Hathaway’s investment
in sweets. It owns American
manufacturer See’s Candies.
That prompted some cheeky tweets from Musk:
“Then I’m going to build a moat
& fill it with candy. Warren B
will not be able to resist investing!
Berkshire Hathaway kryptonite…”
And that wasn’t the end of his tweets over sweets:
“I’m starting a candy company
and it’s going to be amazing”
“I am super super serious”
Fair to say Musk is not actually
serious about starting a candy company.
However, he and Buffett are directly
competing against each other.
Berkshire Hathaway is gaining a foothold
in the growing electric vehicle market.
Over a decade ago, Buffett’s business
partner Charlie  Munger convinced him to pick up
an obscure Chinese automaker. BYD - Build
Your Dreams - is a competitor to Tesla.
For his part, Musk is poised to take on the
car insurance industry where
Buffett is heavily invested.
In a previous video, I talked about how Tesla
plans to start selling personal car insurance
in more U.S. states with Musk predicting that
it could one day account for
a third of Tesla’s business.
That would put Tesla on a collision
course with Berkshire Hathaway.
About a third of its business is
in insurance, including GEICO.
Buffett brushes off any sense
of threat, once remarking:
“I’d bet against any company in the
auto business (getting into insurance).”
On Rogan’s podcast, Musk said he felt
there were two kinds of billionaires who
shouldn’t be seen as one in the same: those
who got rich from engineering and designing
a product and those who made an incredible
amount of money playing the stock market.
Though that seems like a harsh assessment,
Musk did add that he does see
value in what Buffett does.
He used the example of trying to figure out
whether to invest in Coca-Cola or Pepsi.
Musk said it was “a boring job” to decide which
one deserves more capital but
ultimately an important job.
And speaking of coke, it just happens to be
one of Buffett’s favorite investments and
soft drinks. He downs up to five cans a day
including one that he has every morning
with his $3 and change McDonald’s breakfast.
Buffett is known for living very frugally.
The Oracle of Omaha still lives in the same house
in Omaha that he purchased in 1958 for $31,500.
Musk lives well below his means, too.
He’s been known to camp out at Tesla’s
factories when the going has gotten tough.
And his main residence in Boca Chica,
in south Texas is said to be a
house valued at just $50,000.
They also have something else in common. They’ve
pledged to give away most of their fortune.
In the case of Musk, he’s
promised to give away half
on Earth and half on Mars, to build a city there.
If you want to stay up to date on the latest
news about Elon Musk and his companies,
or Warren Buffett and his investments,
you can sign up for a FREE newsletter,
Morning Brew, which sponsored this video.
That’s where I learned about
Musk’s recent tiff with Apple
and the interesting comments he made about Apple
during Tesla’s second-quarter earnings call.
What I really like about Morning Brew is
that it’s quick and easy to read. It only
takes 5 minutes, and then you’re up to date
on the latest business and tech news.
And again, Morning Brew is completely FREE.
All you have to do is enter your
email and you’re good to go.
You can sign up by using my
custom ink in the description.
For Newsthink, I’m Cindy Pom.